the last Super Bowl was played right  here  Jason tell me was it last night classic  game 80,000 people in the region seconds  left on the clock  so Hubie throws a Hail Mary 166 back  online sixty years ago birth was  attacked we won the war but they  destroyed half the planet everyone's  been evacuated nothing human remains  yeah we're here for drone repair with a  mop-up crew  this is Jack Harper I'm good to go to  movies Jack then we can finally leave  and join the others don't take any  chances  I've been watching you jack you're  curious what are you looking for in  those books do they bring back old  memories don't ask too many questions  they are human how do you know they're  firing a survivor  a fighting  that's where you'll find  you need to know that  tell me who are you  Jackson is ordering to stand out I'm not  gonna do that  this is the only way  you